are you looking to run machine learning
on docker containers in the cloud future
proofing your workflow allowing you to
use any library of your choice
if so then you've come to the right
place because today we're going to run
custom containers on Google cloud a high
platform
[Music]
welcome to AI adventures where we
explore the art science and tools of
machine learning my name is Yu Feng Guo
and on this episode we're going to use
AI platforms custom containers to see
how to run custom trained jobs on Google
cloud using docker containers this
approach gives us a number of key
benefits first is faster startup time if
you use a custom container with all of
your dependencies pre-installed
you can save the time that your training
application would otherwise take to
install those dependencies when starting
up so that gives you faster training and
fewer Network and compute resources used
second you can use any machine learning
framework you want just install your
chosen framework in your custom
container and then just use it to run
those jobs on a platform this not only
means you can use every tool Under the
Sun but it also future proofs your
workflow allowing you to easily switch
libraries or add new ones for
experimentation third and this is a
little bit related to the previous point
you can use the latest build of a
library or if you want an older version
if that's what you're relying on that's
great too no one will force you to
update if you're not ready it's your
container it's also worth pointing out
that since you're building your own
container image that if you want a
certain functionality you're gonna have
to install it so if you want something
like hyper parameter tuning or GPU
support you'll need to make sure to
include the necessary libraries to make
those features work ok let's look at how
you can use custom containers to train a
model we're going to try to use PI torch
to train on M NIST
just to show off the tooling and process
first things first
we've got to create the container now I
know that some parts of the data science
community are a bit against learning yet
another tool to do their work but I'm
hoping that you're here to learn
new things plus it definitely seems like
containers are here to stay so it will
be really useful to learn this tool our
docker file installs PI torch cloud ml
hyper tune and downloads GS util for
exporting cloud storage then it
configures some paths finally it copies
in the training code and then sets it up
to run right when the container starts
executing be sure to test your dock and
for locally before you use it by
building that image and running it then
you can push it off to Google container
registry or GCR that's where AI platform
will look for your image during the
training job once you have your image
upload it to GCR creating a job is quite
similar to normal usage of the eye
platform training there's just one extra
command-line argument when you submit
that training job you want to make sure
you include - - master image URI and
pass in that GCR URI at this point you
might be wondering why go through all
the trouble of building a docker image
if we could just run the training
locally there is a couple of scenarios I
can imagine where this would be
particularly useful perhaps your data is
larger than your machine storage or the
data set is secured behind permissions
so you can't run the full training job
on a local machine or maybe the compute
resources of your local machine just
aren't adequate because you need
something like multiple GPUs third
reason might be that you want to do
distributed training across many
machines or you want to run many jobs in
parallel to each other or you just
really like working with containers hey
that's always a possibility for those
who need containers a iya platform
training with custom containers provides
a great new set of features and
functionality to explore I can't wait to
hear about how you containerized your
model thanks for watching this episode
of cloud AI adventures and if you
enjoyed it click that like button and be
sure to subscribe to get all the latest
episodes right when it come out for now
check out AI platform custom containers
for all your custom training needs
[Music]